كثيرون هم من يعتقدون بوجود الكائنات
الفضائيه وينسجون الروايات والاساطير
حولها افلام سينما وقصص واطفال وحتى برامج
وثائقيه صورت سكان الفضاء باشكال واحجام
مختلفه وقدرات خارقه رؤوس وعيون كبيره
اطراف كثيره الوان غريبه وغيرها من الصفات
العجيبه البعض قالوا انهم راهم بام اعينهم
يهبطون بمركباتهم الفضائيه في زيارات
خاطفه لكوكبنا واخرون الدعوه انهم تواصلوا
معهم برسائل مشفره
خرافات كثيره نسجت حول علم الفضاء المجهول
لكن اصواتا بدات تعلو خلال السنوات
الاخيره تؤكد وجودهم وتحذر من غزواتهم
مهلا لا تتعجلوا بالحكم فتلك الاصوات ليست
لاصحاب الخرافات بل هي توقعات لعلماء
الفلك والفضاء مبنيه على معطيات وحقائق
نستذكرها معا خلال هذه الفيديوهات
[موسيقى]
تلك الفيديوهات كانت سريه ثم كشف عنها
البنتاجون منذ بضعه اشهر وقال انها لاجسام
غريبه تطير بسرعه هائله رصدتها البحريه
الامريكيه بين عامي 2004 و2015
ناس ايضا ومؤسساتي بحوث اخرى نشرت عده
اكتشافات حديثه حول دلائل على وجود حياه
خارج كوكب الارض احدث تلك الاكتشافات
يتعلق بكوكب الزهره حيث اكتشف علماء من
جامعه كارديف البريطانيه وجود غاز
الفوسفين في الغلاف الجوي للزهره
الفوسفين غاز عديم اللون وسام جدا
تنتجه على الارض الكائنات المجهريه التي
لا تحتاج الى الاكسجين اقترح في عام 2019
البحث عن هذا الغاز في الكواكب الخارجيه
كعلامه لوجود الحياه عليها
قبل نحو شهر من اليوم توقع عالم الفضاء
والفلك الاسباني
اسرائيليان في تصريحات لصحيفه الصن
البريطانيه هبوط كائنات فضائيه ذكيه على
الارض خلال السنوات
قائلا ان هذا الاكتشاف سيهز البشريه
[موسيقى]
وفي احدى الدراسات الحديثه توصل العلماء
الى ان وجود مخلوقات حيه خارج الارض قد
يكون اكثر شيوعا مما كانوا يعتقدونه
الباحثون قالوا ان كل نوع من الحياه
الفضائيه قد يكون موجودا في نظام نجمي
مختلف تماما عن غيره اضافه الى ان تلك
النجوم التي تستضيف كائنات حيه بعيده جدا
عن كوكبنا
قبل حوالي سنتين عثرت المركبه اوزريس ريكس
التابعه لناسا على مكونات للمياه على
كويكب صغير يدعى بينو فيما عدى انجازا
كبيرا يمهد لمزيد من الاكتشافات في
المستقبل
واضافه لكل ذلك لا تزال الابحاث متواصله
حول دلائل الحياه على كوكب المريخ وبينما
تستمر وكالات الفضاء ببحثها في عالم
الكواكب الفسيح يبقى السؤال الجدلي يطرح
نفسه هل هناك كائنات فضائيه او حياه خارج
الارض وان وجدت هل سنتمكن يوما من التواصل
مع هذه الكائنات